welcome back to King spots continuing
coverage of e3 2014 I've made the
transition game spot stage over there
some some stage over here I'm we're
nearly done we got a bit I don't know
four or five hours left we still got a
bunch of great games coming up air
Macrina Nosgoth codename steam which was
announcement intended yesterday but I'm
very happy to be joined by John Needham
head of Lionhead sir great to be here
thank you
fable legends you guys have been showing
it off you I think you did a good job of
explaining it at the the conference on
Monday you know but for the folks who
don't know any about this game how is it
different from the fable games they've
seen in the past we're calling in a
multiplayer online quest adventure game
so it features four player co-op as
heroes against the villain player who's
a real player masterminding the game
against the euros so you were playing as
one individual person but you're teaming
up with three other human characters
yeah or human characters or you can play
the game single-player as well with AI
companions in an AI villain or you and I
could go in and we could play with two
AI companions in an AI villain any
combination words so you get just could
you go in and it just be the villain
yeah you could be that we'll probably
use that as part of the training for
villain mode right yeah of course and
okay so fable Isaac I gained a lot of
people associate with I am creating this
character yeah I live inside of this
world yep and then I venture outwards
and go on quests as I see fit
yeah this is much more of a directive
focused kind of game in terms of the
quests and dungeons you'll be it's kind
of like a dungeon crawler in a way well
I would say it's close to actually the
traditional table I mean I'd like you to
describe the game as take traditional
table bolt this new modern multiplayer
on to it and that's fable legends so the
there is a narrative in the game an
arcing storyline it takes place over a
series of episodes so it's very much
like a TV program
there'll be fifteen episodes in a season
they're about half an hour of peace and
you'll play through those with your buds
or not against real villains so are you
gonna be releasing those would it be in
one chunk of chunk at launch and then
we're service based game so we've got a
five to ten year plan for paper legends
we're gonna continue to Reese release
episodes new content new features as we
go cool
folks at home to know that if you have
any questions at all please at Danny
O'Dwyer on Twitter and I'll do my best
to get them over to John so in terms of
the fable or because I've already had a
bunch on Twitter asking about that this
is said 400 years prior to the first
game is that correct the first game yeah
I mean we saw people three and it got
very kind of steam punk a lot of
Technology we wanted to take it back to
a time in the history where there's a
lot more magic the world was a lot
darker more dangerous heroes had to band
together and go out an adventure
together in the world and it's kind of
the whole story lines around the rise of
the heroes in the fable universe but
while it's all dark and dangerous it's
not that serious we want to keep all
that English charm and humor in the game
everything in the papal fans really love
about Babel which is something you're
used to after you've been living in
London for a while and I've gotten a ton
of that over the past year but I'm a
huge fan you know I've been a huge fan
of the people franchise since people too
in fact I didn't really like papal 1
when it came out we did a remaster
version this last year I played through
it a couple times it's amazing so it was
great grounding for the team really to
revisit papal one but we're all just
super papal nerds cool I think we can
take a look at some gameplay of it as
well here which might give context for
the folks at home so basically just talk
about the moments a moment action what's
happened this is the beginning of an
adventure it's called moon on a stick
the group of Heroes is trying to
progress through the level to get a
relic the moon on a stick this character
that we're following right now is
curling curling is kind of your classic
roguelike character does a lot of damage
but he can't take a punch at all
sterling not playing too smartly here
should probably stay with the members of
the party cuz he really as I mentioned
can't take much damage this character at
the bottom of the hill is winter she's a
character of will she's kind of a
support class in the game she freezes
creatures and then damage dealers come
in they clean them up I did these and
four characters are they preset does
everyone who joins the party have to
pick one of those well it's not so we
have six characters that were six years
we're showing at the show we'll have a
lot more for release and you'll take
those characters you'll level them up
you'll customize them with weapons and
armor
well I've skill trees form so you can
really make them your own we'll have a
hair cutting Swan in the main town that
you can go in you can change your
appearance too so it's pretty much like
orginal table with more heroes because
it's really about the rise of the
neurosis
excellent and what you're seeing now is
the villain is doing a very common
tactic dropping a bunch of smoke bombs
on the heroes then letting loose with a
bunch of creatures there's probably some
mines that were in there and there's an
artillery red cap that's the creatures
you're seeing right now these red caps
they dip their caps and pools the blood
that's kind of comes up yeah that's a
little gross and this is a puck puck is
a really dangerous character it can go
invisible and ambush heroes this kind of
damage unless it freezes us yeah exactly
good thing that winter showed up because
sterling would have a tough time against
puck one-on-one Cobain's so that the
challenge in this game and you said that
the episodes are gonna be about thirty
minutes yep each what does I present in
terms of replayability and difficulty
yeah I mean that is the great thing
about the villain mode so the villain
you'll see it in a second lays down all
the creatures in the map you can take
the creatures and target certain heroes
as abilities like being able to raise
and lower gates and separate the heroes
from their group so a lot of different
variety you know of experience when you
go in and plus well a bunch of Heroes
different combinations to go play
through these adventures there'll be a
lot of loot drops that you'll be getting
as you play through them excellent I'm
so ton of replayability I'm getting a
bunch of questions in already and I just
want to get through a couple of them
here and James is asking and what's what
platforms is his head on obviously looks
gorgeous involved well Xbox one were
really focused on right now the power
the box were using unreal for we
actually had Tim Sweeney from epic out
to the studio like six months ago
because we're one of the earlier
developers on Unreal 4 yeah he said we
had the best foliage he's ever seen he
says that 360 version of a fable legends
xbox one and then for instance the the
villains stuff cannot be done on Xbox
one as well or is it
in fact we're trying to build a couch
clients as well for billing okay I don't
have a solution yet but we'll have it by
the time we get to launch where a player
can play on the couch as billing on a
mobile device against someone sitting in
the room playing a hero another
excellent and this this mode just real
quick this is the villain perspective so
it's very top-down perspective kind of
RTS style I so much you can see him
moving creatures around the map and the
interface this was tricky actually
trying to map RTS style controls you a
controller but and we went through a few
iterations and I think we've come up
with something that's that's pretty
great and easy easy learn so on the left
hand side do you see the heroes they're
all on the d-pad on the right hand side
or other creatures they're on the face
buttons so you can select a hero with
the d-pad then select creatures and the
creatures will attack that here so it's
one of the tactics that a villain can
use to try to where the heroes down and
this game is really it's a game of
attrition so the villain they have a
bunch of creatures there's trying to do
as much damage to the heroes as they can
until the final engagement where the big
monster comes out and hopefully the
villain not the villain kills the heroes
and I'm getting a sort of perhaps it's
appropriate I'm getting sort of a
dungeon keeper vibe sitting line which
I'd agree exactly deep in our heritage
you can call this kind of a lion head
mashup right we're taking all of our
experience and God games and fable and
we're mashing them together I'm kind of
bunch more questions here and it feels
like everyone is asking a question that
I was asking when I was watching the
trailer and money stick I'm gonna give a
shout out today on this one and will
there be any chicken chasing or chicken
cake so we have this town bright lodge
it's the central hub in the world it's
gorgeous
you will be partying doing emotes on
other NPCs and people real people too
you know we're gonna have your friends
flowing through bright Lodge chicken
kicking it's all there all those classic
kind of fable tropes there was a chicken
kick in the trailer though there was it
we're saving that was that intention
saving because everyone walked past the
chicken and I was a here comes here
comes here comes now now now alright we
have some next gen chicken kicking and
that will be announcing soon team
Sweeney says it's
chicken kicking he's seen exactly
exactly
so bright lodges it's really cool it's a
social hub of minigames so that players
can play it's kind of the place they can
go chill out all the semi elements they
love about fable will happen there and
you'll have a ton of NPCs with character
like you used to be picking up local bar
maids and the pub there you know doing
all that sort of thing which I
particularly love well you haven't when
you have a house or anything like that
it's about hustling yet obviously we
want to do that that's a big part of the
people experience as well it'll come at
some point but a cool thing is you know
with your friends being in the game
they'll actually flow through your
bright Lodge that's where you'll group
up and you go out on adventures together
that all happens in the cloud so some of
the cool things working on xbox one they
have this amazing live and cloud
infrastructure that we can use for
features like that excellent John
Needham flying head studio is an
absolute pleasure having the legends
that when is it out and again I'm we're
going into beta this Paul go to people
legends comm sign up and when the game
is awesome we'll release awesome so much
a designer pedigree we've got Andrew
Tsubaki up next with Greg ooh of course
the Westwood veteran himself but stick
around we'll be back with another five
minutes slam I believe Lisa is checking
it destiny